who's gonna be the first man in space we
have this idea of the mercury seven and
the men are the heroes here's this story
that we know so much about
what are the parts that we don't know
that's one of the things i love the most
about this show is that it dives into
that
trudy she was a pilot it was a really
tough time to be
a female pilot trudy and gordo had a
deep love for the same thing
space flying her husband raised his
planes i do
she's looking at these men and thinking
is there a world in which i could do
that
she separated from gordo nasa told him
that if they
didn't have home lives that were stable
then they couldn't be astronauts and so
he begged her to come back
i need a big favor this is a fresh start
for us i spent a lot of time thinking
about like why would she come back it's
space
trudy please at the time there was no
way for women to be
involved in this program and the closest
that she could ever get to space
was actually through him astronaut
i want to do it considering
the limitations that women had on them
at this time
it was really important for me to show
that louise was a true partner
in this relationship she was his
confidant alan got to
where he got because she was the person
who helped him
strategize and figure out which
direction to take things are different
now
and john glenn's good at it so if you
really want to be
first you're going to have to get used
to the limelight
she supported him in these crazy
endeavors that he set out on
and had the same sort of strong will and
determination that he had
don't worry he'll be fine unless john
kills him
i think what was really important for me
to get across with annie is
how strong she was she was very
supportive but she would put him in his
place
kennedy doesn't like the program change
his mind i just find her so fascinating
because she had
so many lives she worked with people
with disabilities and
she got her pilot's license annie
absolutely had the right stuff
this is jerry cobb she's a famous pilot
what's so interesting about this time is
that it was before the sort of idea of
modern feminism
but with grit and determination jerry
cobb hoped for something more
i want to build a female astronaut core
and i want you to be a part of it
what's so appealing about the idea of
the mercury 13 program was that women
were never assumed to have the right
stuff
why'd you stop it because you've been on
it longer than anyone else
ever
we're decades out from when the right
stuff both the movie and the book were
made
it's so interesting to look at this
story with a current lens
and to re-address this story of the
women
the sexism of the time the behind the
scenes can't even imagine the amount of
pressure
that they were under the ambition it
took to try to get beyond obstacles that
they were up against
it's a really powerful thing
you